[Music]
faheem you haven't done the podcast
before this feels weird i haven't i know
i know i feel like we were well i like
that i have a thing that's big enough to
kind of like
hop on
i feel like it's old hollywood and i'm
like doing all the like yeah i'm
promoting my movie like it's top guns
no i'm just like the whitney's podcast
is old hollywood no the way hollywood
used to be you know where it was a movie
tv show but like this is the late night
circuit now it's so true yeah and you
know what is so crazy i feel like this
is just worth saying because i always
think things that are too inside
baseball aren't interesting also by the
way we're talking to faheem anwar uh
brilliant comedian uh special out now on
youtube called hat trick i watched it
with my dude last night and it's the
first time we've ever agreed on
something being good it's the first time
we've ever
like liked the same thing
uh there's a joke in it that he is so
obsessed with that
that is the um
when someone uh your ubereats person or
your postmates person brings you food in
a tesla and you're like dude you know
you could just drive a civic and not do
this
you know like he hands you a burrito and
then he's like
how do you
it's like that gull wing door like you
should be doing uber and then pulling
your door down like you should be
handing me a two dollar burrito and then
be like shit going to the moon yeah it's
like they jumped the gun on the car ah
they're doing it's they're breaking even
yeah uber like they're paying their
their car their tesla bill with the
burritos just get a point eight a point
get a honda civic and then don't have to
do that yeah it's also it's like are you
on auto drive on ubereats that would be
nice use almost chinese food and
burritos and you're just like hands
off to all the locations technically i'm
not an ubereats driver my car my car is
my tesla's doing it i'm not doing the
driving
i'm not a driver for ubereats you crazy
my tesla is i'm just a human i'm just
the human that steals the poke yeah i
just punch in the address and go
they're just so like you are so
brilliant at these little observation
you know what you're one of the few
comics that you'll have an observation
and i'll be like fuck
you know when someone has such a good
like everyone's done who eats jokes
everyone's on an uber drive ever and
then you fucking have like an angle that
no one else has and you're just like ah
like it makes me those are the comedians
i love the most the ones that make me a
little angry and jealous that's
flattering well you know in comedy
sometimes you'll hear oh you don't talk
about airlines or you don't talk about
just things that are well tread
but i don't think that's true i think if
your angle is unique enough you can
definitely shed new light on any topic
that's been you know and it's the
perfect time to do stuff like that
because everyone's shied away from it
for so long i'm like we are due for a
new airplane food sure bit but also
everyone's brain is different there was
a
night at the laugh factory you were
doing some joke about taco bell um
i wonder what the like neighbors there
was there was i remember this set
because i remember
watching you this was recent and i
remember watching you and going i need
to get that levity like i need he's
doing things that actually make him
laugh like you do this little thing at
the end where you're like
you're like the pillsbury doughboy yeah
i try not to do it too much but like
it's so fun here's the thing well what i
realized
maybe this was a breakthrough for me
a couple years ago maybe like six or
eight years ago you forget that this is
supposed to be fun forget you do like
we're doing stand up sometimes people
could be so self serious and like i've
got to have the sharpest jokes and be
this so acerbic and cool
that but we're we're telling jokes we're
trying to make a room laugh and i just
found i operate best
when i am happy and when i am enjoying
it as much as the audience like somebody
laughing in the crowd
will make will kind of make me laugh
imagine if you like
when there's other performers that you
don't get to not imagine like a stripper
just being like
going through the motions like you're
not you just you have to
enjoy what you're doing or don't show up
like that was something for me i
realized like two years ago before the
pandemic i was like if i'm not feeling
it i just shouldn't go that's how
important my energy is to this working
it's also like clothes that you try on
and when you first do stand up you don't
really know what you are what like what
you should be revving at okay i'm
changing my analogy you're you're a car
you don't know what your optimal
yeah rpms are all right
you know how good of a car guys
all right all right let's move to a
different analogy
but you're just trying on things well no
because my brain just goes i'm like my
two joke machine i go why are cars and
boats called her why are they she
i wanted a joke that's that's like joke
structure but in terms of delivery and
presentation and vibe like i just found
that i'm a silly i'm silly guy i do have
smart jokes and stuff but like
me being in that emotional state is the
best delivery system for my comedy
whereas that wouldn't work on gesselnick
that doesn't like i can't do what
gesselnick does like jesselnik has to be
the cool guy with the dark jokes
um so it's not what i look back and find
out he was just anemic this whole time
he was like you guys i would love to be
more hyped i don't want to do act out
but i just i i just had a higher
deficiency did no one notice like could
anyone have helped me please i've had
mono for 12 years you guys
i'm a very physical comedian i couldn't
even bring my props yeah i just found
that i'm a guy who likes to play yeah
i'm a comedian who likes to play but
that's our job like to me there's room
for everyone whatever you do cool but
like i take my job as a clown very
seriously so to me it's like now more
than ever like we don't need i don't
lecture people i don't talk about
politics i don't tell you how to vote
it's not going to be on your the time
that you signed up for jokes to happen
so it's like imagine like going to a
hardware store and they're like we've
got we have we have a couple hammers but
we just got all these new oranges in we
got and you're just like why am i
why aren't you making me laugh and also
as a comedian i didn't sign up to be a
serious person that lectured people on
how to vote i don't need to know what i
don't know what prop 52 is i don't i'm
not going to post about it like i'm just
i'm going to
tell silly stupid jokes yes
by the way for an hour and my new
special i think i'm going to call it
just jokes what do you think i like it
it's just jokes i think people want that
nowadays too beginning to end only jokes
and i like being nimble as well so okay
i can do maybe a serious topic but then
do something completely dumb just we're
not we don't have to be you know what it
is it's not hoodwinking you under the
guise of i'm gonna make you laugh and
then sneaking in a ted talk yes yes
it's like if i'm gonna do my ted talk
i'll do it on ted. sure yeah you'll do
it then
like i just don't think it's fair to for
comedians to hoodwink people
and have them pay money and to
then trick them by being like you're a
piece of shit you're racist you suck
they're like we're
i thought i was a good person i donate
to charity no you're a fucking idiot you
have one different view than me yeah
like how dare you i'm i'm out of this ha
ha yeah it's called the ha ha hut why is
anyone offended in a if rooster t
feathers are penguins imagine
fuck this penguins that comedian just
made a rape joke you're in penguins yeah
you know you know what the deal is yeah
i like to say like call it dolphins
cause they rape people you're gonna come
out of my show and you're gonna learn
nothing
that's my promise to you yeah you'll
enjoy yourself but you're not gonna you
will your life won't be changed
you will leave
not being qualified nothing i do is
brave
i promise you you're not gonna grow as a
human
i'm not you're not gonna know any more
about legislatures or abortion access it
is strange like they're i kind of want
to talk about like how
stand-up has
there's a schism in stand-up
there's just traditional stand-up jokes
and bringing levity to a room and then
there's a faction of schism schism yeah
i don't know what that means it's like a
fracture i had to say this today to
someone um
you guys emily decided to come to work
the jeopardy judges like schism is that
a word by the way the judges are saying
it isn't working i didn't embarrass
myself
no s-c-h-i-s-m
um i think liz just said you're not
allowed to say that word
no no no schism is a split
it is a split or division between
strongly opposed sections or parties
caused by differences in opinion or
belief wow you think you're so smart
just because you can read
okay you just promised us we would get
stupider and you're making us smarter
fuck not bad no but really quick uh for
context um so emily got a boyfriend you
guys so it's anyone's guess if we're
gonna be able to keep shooting this
podcast um today she just we were
supposed to it's why i look like um a
rat king it's like why i look like theo
van today um because emily was just woke
up she was like i'm just in bed in my
love cocoon
and i checked my phone
wait this is so much harder i don't even
vape i vaped all the way to work i found
one in my car you're stoned right now no
it's nicotine
what it's a nicotine pen are you
[Laughter]
i do by the way
it is so weird i have to admit this so i
had to stay in another house during the
pandemic um
uh because my house was under
construction and i like kept getting
amazon packages over there and the one
was like can you please can pick up your
amazon packages and i was like i guess i
could ask grace to do it but
she's too busy and so i was
and um and so
uh okay so i go over at night to pick up
the packages i'm like fuck it i'll just
pick up this fucking after the economy
store when i i go and there's like a
gate you remember it
i pull up
uh i go to press in the code and i i had
a this was like a new car and i didn't
put it in park and i stopped and it just
lurched into the
fucking gate and i pull out quietly and
i just started like being like okay i'm
just gonna say that there was a car
behind me and it was there was the
sprinkler i just started coming up with
a lie it's hilarious i do that too and
then like by like five minutes later i
was like
okay i'm just gonna tell her i came over
at night
and i missed the break and i hit your
fence and i'm just going to pay for the
damage like i just but it took a w
i was like i'm going to say that someone
stole my car and saw i was like why am i
doing it yeah sometimes the truth is so
much easier than the lie this might be a
generational thing the idea of us anyone
messing up
is
it is i would rather lie for years to
you whereas like my assistant grace
she's 26 now 27
45 25. um uh she's 35. um
she's aged 10 years since doing this job
um
if she forgets something she'll just
like i forgot so i'd be like this like i
forgot and i feel really bad about it so
i need to take a mental health day
like what it's wait this is i feel so
bad that i forgot and i'm
i don't want to get in trouble with hr
so can you drive me home how long do you
got to take off maybe a month this is
really weighing on me
on the way here i was like i need a
vacation
i mean it is it is a different thing
like i there's no
like it's like yeah i made a mistake and
you know what i should get more points
for that because i'm being authentic and
telling you the truth not only will they
tell you that they
forgot they want points for being
authentic i have never fucked up like
this i almost broke up with houston this
morning i was like
why are you bringing him into it
because you've texted he's the only
reason you could fun to hang out with
lately
please don't get rid of him oh god then
we have to go back to you just like
fucking random strangers in austin
gotta keep houston well that was him oh
sorry
you gotta keep this random stranger
i was talking to him earlier i am going
to crush at your wedding so hard that's
the weird thing about white weddings is
that when they give the speeches like
the best man they'll just talk about
previous times the groom fucked some
rando and tijuana like you know dan
junior tijuana and you know he had fun
in that whorehouse and uh but he's you
know my best friend like that would be
mortified they're like but jenny
you turned him into a gentleman yeah
we never thought we'd see
in this you know
and we never thought this day yeah like
that would be a generational catastrophe
at an
the family would have to move somewhere
else and like yeah witness protection
just change their face just stone
themselves
yeah it's just you would have to change
your face
oh my god that'd be hilarious just like
what they do for criminals just for
slight uh
you know infractions i'm gonna start any
time i like get my like face done which
i will be doing in a couple of years i'm
just gonna be like i disgraced my family
to change my everything yeah like you
get a report card it's like face-off
just
i really do not stand by my last special
i'm just gonna become a new comedian i'm
gonna start over i'm gonna give montreal
new faces and just start from scratch
but it's just like so funny to me like
just the idea because i feel like
comedians we always get asked to speak
at our friend's weddings i actually
don't like uh because it's a different
thing my brain compartmentalizes
speaking into different types of mediums
so like stand up i'm a fish in water i'm
a duck in water whatever like okay it's
easy because it's my thoughts and i i'm
i'm able to talk about i've been
thinking about these jokes
but whenever i do a wedding or something
it feels like i'm giving a presentation
in high school one of the funniest uh
things in your new special so i watched
it with my guy last night we were
screaming crying uh when uh
the idea of when you're like white
families when something goes wrong in
the family they're like yeah mark's
addicted to meth
it's so true yeah they sent out a
newsletter
it's like the premise is like white
families are too honest
you know like they'll be like
travis is addicted to math
and like brown families wouldn't do that
they would spin it they'd be like abdul
cleans the house constantly
it's like because we're all about
keeping up appearances
so like even the wedding thing i was
talking about it's like you have to have
the squeaky clean image there's the
family name
everyone is flawless or at least on the
veneer what is it abdul started a
business oh yeah go where'd your where'd
your tv go abdul started his own
business
[Laughter]
just putting a positive spin on
everything like he sold our
it's just like it's so like
god it's so funny you're so funny and
you're not like trying to be i just feel
like i see a lot of comedians around
trying to say something they shouldn't
say it's like there's so much comedy and
things that we all can agree
yeah there's a lot of colors to paint
with sometimes you forget as a con can
we just clip that please there's a lot
of colors to paint with
that's what's like
whitney's podcast
now he's gay
but you can get so uh you know
microscopic with you know being the cool
guy and stuff and also okay i've gotta
hit these third rails and talk about all
these social issues
but it's just a microphone on a stage
and it's such a blank canvas sometimes
we forget that sometimes i'll do a thing
on the road if i want to keep it
interesting like i have an idea
i don't do it anymore but i had this one
bit where i'm doing some impressions i'm
like this is my impression of a guy at a
concert who's enjoying himself but he
can't completely let go and then i take
my jacket off and i'm holding it and
they play this drake song
and then i'm just kind of like vibing
out like really tiny like super vibing
out
it's just a funny visual with the music
and it's like this set piece that isn't
traditional jokes and it's fun to be
like oh yeah you can do anything it's a
sandbox one of my favorite uh like you
i i i aspire to be one of these people i
don't know if i'm there yet but you are
someone that has
found your thing on social media in a
way that is not embarrassing or cringy
or corny like comedians send around your
videos without making fun of you which
is very that's nice unusual there's one
where you did it was um an audition your
audition for playing the invisible man
you were playing you know you were
playing a victim of the
yeah because i had just seen the
invisible man the one with elizabeth
yeah yeah
i was laughing i was
laughing about domestic abuse it was so
well just the visual i know supposed to
be serious and it's a serious topic and
all that but just saying the invisible
man seeing elizabeth moz get beat up by
nothing
was like hysterical to me i'm like
crying she's just showing off as an
actress at this point yeah i'm like i
know what that guy looks like based on
what you yeah we're supposed to be
scared but i'm just like crying laughing
because nothing is happening to her and
she's so then i had the idea for the
instagram video where i'm like fahim
anwar this is um i'm auditioning for the
invisible man and i have sides in my
hand you know i'm in sweatpants at my
house you know and i go
and i put the i think the
camera
and i go
wait a minute
so you're telling me there's some sort
of invisible man out there
and then i just beat myself up like and
then i get up off the ground and i'm
like 5 10 i am willing to shave
don
associates the associates not don
i'm working on a bit about
blonde privilege
so it's about how racism can never be
fixed until the
schism
within the white community is
acknowledged of the within white
privilege there is a sub there is a
blonde privilege that's so funny and
blonde people have no idea how the world
it's not their fault they just don't
know how the world works and brunettes
like we can only do so much without
blondes acknowledging because they
we need them to help us because
politicians all the lawmakers are
married to them they won't marry us so
until blondes i do love that concept
beyond privilege
it's like
blondes like all my blonde friends like
they just don't have a concept of
consequences and it's so funny as they
age
that they they don't realize that it's
starting to go like all my blonde
friends like when we go in public
they're like i don't wait in lines
you're like oh wait we have okay one day
we have to we but like brunettes no it
was like when the elizabeth holmes thing
happened i was like how
did an 18 year old girl get a billion
dollars from a bunch of men in their 70s
brunettes are like we know exactly
we could have told you exactly how that
was going to go like when the elizabeth
holmes situated when she was running
around trying to get money for investors
a bunch of brunette scientists that were
like 40 were like oh we can make a blood
we know how to do this we can they're
not even looking at her in the eyes like
yeah yeah i can give you that money
no literally everyone's like hey
brunette scientist can you shut up the
18 year old blonde had some good points
doctor please shut up what were you
saying elizabeth like and then they're
just giving this guy like we know i know
what that is you know and then like i
remember um i was at a wedding a friend
of mine's wedding and i brought a
girlfriend of mine who's blonde and the
wedding was at like i don't know four or
something and three i was like should we
like have a drink she really have a
drink before the wedding she would be
like naughty and she went oh i took a
molly at noon
i was like what the fuck are you she
hugged the groom for two minutes
straight she's on molly and then hugging
the groom i'm like oh god but then the
wife is a friend of mine also brunette
we just look at each other and we're
like ones like we think we look at you
like a puppy that doesn't know any
better if that was a brunette we'd be
like that bitch just tried to steal your
fucking man i got my a blonde we're just
like wow she doesn't know you don't they
don't like it's like it's not that
they're dumb it's just that
they people tried to molest them their
whole childhood so they just got so much
free candy and free rides
i'm just saying blondes just there's a
someone will always catch your problem
will always be solved like i was blonde
for three months yeah what was that like
i'm curious there's a whole other world
out there that brunettes don't know
about there's a there's a their chefs
can make things that aren't on the menu
do you have tangible examples do you
have tangible examples of what happened
and look at the menu and be like um do
you have um napolitan ice cream souffle
they'll be like i'll get it you know
what let me check with you i think we'll
where's the brunette if you're like can
i get the dressing on the side they're
like chef makes it the way chef makes it
no subs
we don't do subs
it's just broccoli for green beans
also there's no way as a brunette to
like
make yourself like like prettier in a
way of first of all to be a brunette
beauty you have to be the most beautiful
person on the planet i will say another
subset of the blonde is the platinum
blonde and that's even i i think that is
a thing where the hair is so bright
you're like i'm not even seeing a face
anymore and guys are just like it's like
looking into the sun and they're like i
think she's hot
it's just so bright you're like and
she's so poisoned for peroxide she can't
see you either yeah i think she's hot
her hair says hot i don't know what it
is like what about the blonde i'm trying
to think it's like because at the end of
the day sex isn't like do you just want
it to look like david bowie is like in
your day maybe it's just rarer you know
and is it a biological thing or
evolutionary
i think there's also something when
blondes are babies and throughout their
life there's so much like we have to put
sunscreen on you yeah like you whereas
if you're a brunette everyone's like
that's fine they just leave you with six
flags on the roller coaster you come
back just like rap just no one put
sunscreen on me when i was a kid like i
don't know what no one
like no one tries to find brunette girls
when they're lost like there's a whole
tv channel she'll find her way home yeah
she'll be fine
and so that is like an area that i'm
like worried about because i have a
little bit of like girls aren't going to
like me but it rings true to me
i i buy it i think it's great yeah i
think
it's gonna be great on stage um that's
something i've worked what because i get
so excited after i've have a special
like in the can like what is something
you're working on
what bit mm-hmm i actually i mean i
haven't it's my favorite thing to do
what the balance premise is anything
that you have nothing even if you have
not one joke i've got one here
yeah give it so like i was watching some
interview with like jack harlow you know
yeah it was like on reels or something
he's like
you know i've always been about that bag
you know i've been getting a bag or so
he's talking like that and i just
thought like
if you're 18
or 20 and you're like a white kid y'all
whatever like talking like this and you
do music and stuff like if you hit it
big
you're gonna talk like that forever that
that's locked in because you've been
rewarded by society you're going to get
the money you're going to get the fame
like this is helpful and it's on youtube
the days where you can like change your
thing are over yeah but like you know
the world is telling you this is what
they want so you like locked into this
like until the day you die but if you're
trying to make it and you put your first
album out and don't really hit
my second album it's like a little less
you know
like yeah my second album and then if
you you're working at firestone and
you're 35 you're like yeah we'll have
your car ready and uh we'll have it
ready in about 40 minutes we got your
phone number we'll give you a call like
it has to fade away over time
but if you are like
it's baked in if you hit success at 20
and you're like yo what uh this is what
i do you know i was in the stool and i
got these ideas and then you know kanye
he's sick with the beat and then i ride
that beat and you know we just made
millions of dollars and we just keep
doing that i got the endorsement i do
liquid debt i do monster i do rebel they
don't care that they're competing brands
they don't care because like that's how
hot we are like he's going to talk like
that forever
you adverts you are the face of two
competitors yeah that's how good it is
that's how good we are well see i always
uh and i'm always big on if i have a
joke that works that i don't use i
always want to like pitch another comic
um but uh the idea of like rappers like
are never number two they all think
they're number one like no you can't all
be number one
so the rapper that decides to be like yo
i'm number i'm probably like two or
three but if i just work a little harder
i could be number one but like you know
we all go ebbs and flows like you're on
top and then you you know got you're
back to the bottom again and then you're
on the top again he's like no one's i
know who's number one i can look at the
chart you're not everybody there's a
rapper who's like i'm the second best
rapper yeah or he's content
and the second best i've got i want look
little bags little pouches they have to
be bags just pouches humble wrapper that
always you're so good at like really
specific impressions that don't involve
like having to do like accents and shit
i always want to like do that but i
don't know why i could ever pull it off
but or i never felt
uh confident enough maybe but um
the idea of a uh
a guy who's miming
sports
who's too realistic
so you know when guys like play sports
in line at the grocery store but like
they're just practicing their form
yeah you know they're just like
like and in their head they're seeing it
go in or you know or they're hitting a
golf club a fake golf club and lying for
something
like the idea that a guy is like
like shoots it and it's like ah fuck
he's doing the high fives and his
friends too just like on the missed chat
you're like you didn't need to miss that
it was a fake you could have made it in
your mind like how low is your
self-esteem that you can't make a fake
shot
yeah
on the same lines i always thought there
are certain sports that are okay to
pantomime like like if you're in a
business call and you have the
hands-free and you're just like
practicing a golf swing everyone's okay
with that right
but you can't be like a hockey goalie in
like making or you can't you can't be in
the pocket and be like yeah yeah three
o'clock sounds good
yeah that's funny you can't you also
can't mime like mma you're just like on
the ground
hold my calls all right uh let's push
the lunch meeting to three you can't
there's certain sports you could not
mine while on a call you can't just be
like on a horse uh-huh on a fake horse
like jumping just the bougie white
sports like golf tennis totally
acceptable to practice your form but no
other sport can you like do that no no
no no no no that is a really funny thing
to me is the things you can do on calls
also there's something can we call can
we be done with zoom and all that shit
because i see you checking your email
you fucking idiot why are you checking
your ears i had this writing can't see
your eye line
i had this writing job on zoom for a
little bit during the pandemic so it was
we're writing this tv show and
everyone's on zoom and
there would be times where you you would
just hear like
video someone fucked up oh and then like
it's bound to happen just you know
because everyone's not completely locked
in the entire you might have another tab
open so you'll hear
video of a news thing or someone's
watching a video
and then it goes away and it's like a
case of who done it
you see some person go
well the thing i saw you lurch forward
we know it was you what happened to me
one time but the thing the key is you
have to keep your cool if it's happening
then you just
like close the browser don't let on
because if you panic everyone knows it's
you know but if the sound comes on just
go
just stifle it
close it it's it's like who's watching
for him and mars stand up on youtube
like that's all i do every day
can i try to do your joke about when at
least when a guy is 5 ten he's always
five down when you guys wear makeup at
least at least he doesn't change sizes
when it rains all the time
like if it's if it rains it's not like
yeah
you know because like women have makeup
that can wash off but like the guy's
five nine all the time rain sleet or
snow
why does that sound so funny yeah yeah
cause he's melting and this is fuck
no it is it is like the body positive
women should be able to be any size they
want any age they want but men can't be
bald they have to be five they have to
be like like six four
and never have had dated anyone yes and
they only can have dated fat women
i want body positivity for your exes
like this is like blondes i'm sorry i'm
back on it blondes
blonde feminists or blonde activists are
so funny to me because they're like we
need
child care in the workplace we need
mater more maternal leave and the
brunettes are like hey bitch no one
married us we don't we just want a job
you're like so many men love me that i
have my fifth baby i i i we get it
people want to marry you and fuck you
you need time off we're just trying to
beco get in the mail room yeah we just
want to get off the block i'm like no
one i'm not having any kids no one wants
to marry me i need no time off and i
still can't get hired
and they're like ugh taylor you're hired
there's also certain names we can't have
have you ever met a brunette stephanie
find me one
they don't exist
like imagine seeing like i'm obsessed
with shit like that like imagine
a brunette named
even taylor tiffany
never oh wait stephanie tiffany amber
thesis oh that's tiffany
and then they had to put two names in it
tiffany and amber she was it from yeah
because neither tiffany nor amber could
stand alone for a brunette no we have
tiffany and they have two hot names in
our world
with tiffany amber thiessen you would
think that she'd be like philip seymour
hoffman like this tour de force actor
because she has three names
like have you seen tiffany amber
thiessen's latest project it's riveting
you know what's weird
three names for a guy means you're an
amazing actor three names for a girl
means you like
worked at hooters yeah yeah for
sure it's like people take you less
seriously the more names you have as a
woman people take you more seriously the
more names you have as a man why is it
so funny to me
here we go can you imagine a brunette
jumping out of a birthday cake
you'd be like what the fuck you ruined
the cake call the police
there's gonna be hair on the security
yeah there's gonna be hair on the it's
gonna be gross black hair on the cake
get her get her out of here
can we get a blonde chick in this cake
her hair isn't it that's fine
yes i'm happy with that being in my cake
oh here we go even lesbians date blondes
they know
um oh there's no plus size blonde models
they're just called models like when a
brunette is a size four we're like this
is a plus size model whereas marilyn
monroe is a size 18 and we're like no
she was just perfect
you never see brunettes dancing on a bar
they're like can you be careful i got
you like we let the blondes just step on
our faces
is she a contractor is she like checking
the crown molding up there are we
getting audited by the irs what's that
what's she doing is that the insurance
adjuster checking the tracks you just
give her a drill she's like no i'm
having a good time oh
i thought you were looking at the edison
lighting oh yeah blondes there's this
whole world you don't know about um
brunettes we have to call in advance to
go to a restaurant
well like makeup
like tables just appear for me my
friends you know my friends are like oh
we should make a reservation they're
like bye we'll be fine
like we're going to nobu in four months
we should probably call now oh but they
always have tables when i go
it's different dude when you go i
remember going to aspen and there was a
lunch place that you know the lunch
place that there's like a party at the
lunch place in aspen
and
all the blonde women are on the tables
dancing
and during the day they dance on tables
like during the day for brunch yeah
they're just like i'm like what howard
like i literally was just like trying to
like deep throat like pimento cheese and
like a sloppy joe and they're just like
oh like life is such a party yeah when
you're walking just bopping around um
okay i am oh i also i'm working on is
there any truth in this uh
the 25 year olds i know
are
so stressed out
and have absolutely nothing to do they
are riddled with anxiety i'm like if you
think your life is hard yeah like i'm
like
they are
slammed
they are exhausted they are
anxious they are scared
they
and i don't know of what
um
it they're in a constant state of
terror i'm like you haven't even been in
the dmv yet and you like you're still on
your mom's insurance i'm like you don't
like if you i don't know how to tell
them like it's only gonna get worse i
wonder if they have like new problems
that we can't really fully understand as
an older person like we didn't have the
pressure of instagram tick tock like
some of the bullying that may go on
there
that could be stressors as well
it's like i feel like it's different
yeah like the the kids that were um
working in factories in the 20s like
it's they wouldn't understand what it's
like to to follow kim kardashian and
feel bad about yourself
yeah are we sure we're just cool with
this like i just i i'm just big on like
because i find myself doing it all the
time it's like
girls i know that are 22 they're like i
have anxiety and i have to go to another
psychiatrist appointment then i have to
go to therapy again and then i have to
go get my thing and then i have to go to
my other therapist and then i have to go
to my acupuncturist then i have to deal
with my shoulder thing and i'm like
you should be the healthiest and
happiest you're ever going to be right
now i don't know how to break it to you
that like nothing's wrong well because
we're more open and that's being like
celebrated like
i always have to stop i'll see a video
on instagram or something like when i
have these breakdowns my dog comes and
this woman's on the floor
and the golden retriever comes and like
starts licking her face
like petting the dog yeah and everyone's
like oh my god the dog's so great sorry
going through this but in my mind i'm
like
she set up the camera oh my god
hit record
sat in the corner and
the dog came like
it's almost like throwing up a stand-up
clip or something
if you're still crying after you set up
the camera
also with the episode
it's also weird to be in the middle like
[Music]
hook it up to a tripod
and you set up a boom mic
yeah yeah this one's dancing on camera
it says stripes and everyone's like
you're so brave yes queen i'm sorry
you're going through this
but there's this other layer that people
don't think about like who shot that who
shot you i do when i put auditions on
tape and i have to do between and i'm
like sobbing crying and as soon as i i'm
like i lost it no like there's no way
you're still you're documenting your
breakdown and yeah you can at least like
acknowledge like it was worse now it's
talking to a camera is helping me sure
so it's better you don't have to pretend
like
but we're in a new age where like those
type of videos and the problems are kind
of like a currency it's true it's a form
of to me trauma bonding if you're gonna
go like hey i have this legitimate thing
and i'm sharing with people i'm using my
platform to connect with great but if
your business is something else and then
you're only going to put out stuff where
it's like how sick you are how um
depressed you are how anxious you are
now no one can be honest with you you're
making it so we all treat you with kid
gloves
and then life's going to get worse and
worse because no one tells you the truth
like for me i like those moments are for
some people they're not for everyone and
i think that when we present ourselves
to the world only at our like best it's
bad but only at our worst it's also bad
because it's just gonna be like
everyone's like are you okay how are you
doing like do you want every
conversation to be like are you okay
someone that has blue hair it's very
annoying when that's all people ask you
i always have this thought too with
there's a big push for
um you know mental health and all that
society's going towards that but i
didn't hear that no they're like
championing it and all that but society
kind of only comedian's crazy that's how
we stay funny they only want that from
like celebrities like if demi lovato is
going through a thing everyone's like
yeah yes queen like you're going through
it but if like hey this is bob you had a
mental breakdown he's in our department
everyone isn't like yes questions like
get him out of here they're like what
the fuck have you heard about bob do you
know what it was like does he explode
dude what's the exit to the building
but he's on my team for this project can
we get rid of like can we get a new
person in here that that doesn't crash
yeah no one's like i think it's great
you had a mental breakdown blake and
like
yeah and that you're back on the team
and that's awesome like let me know if i
could help in any way it would just be
breaking like yeah you know like had a
mental breakdown does anybody know so
this whole demi lovato yes queen okay so
his yoga in the fridge can i have it
yeah it doesn't apply to the everyday
person no
no it's only if you're rich if you're
poor and you have a breakdown people
like uh
another fuck too when it comes to you'll
hear news stories about someone losing
their mind or something and part of me
is like
that must be nice
like i would love to lose my like it's
so hard to keep it together day to day
oh i would love to just have that
vacation like
obviously as a comedic take or whatever
but like the freedom of just losing your
mind for a bit
dude when i tell you
when i had blue and pink hair
there is so much freedom and people
already thinking you're insane
you can do anything like this is you
know like when old people just start
shoplifting and no one's gonna stop them
like she's doing it again so my dad used
to um i don't know if your dad's ever
did this or or men in your family he
would shave his face and when he would
get cuts he would put a little piece of
toilet paper on it yeah and just walk
out in public and it's such a when i see
a man with toilet paper on his feeling
oh i'm just like do you want my car like
that's someone that doesn't give a fuck
about anything no no fuck i don't care
about you i don't care about your
fucking car i'm gonna park where i want
i'm gonna park in a handicapped space
like that's just someone to be feared
because it's like no fucks given when i
had pink and blue hair i could
what you're talking about the respite
from reality where you could act so
crazy and people would just like
she's doing pretty good given the
circuit you the bar for you is so low no
one asks you to pick up their kid from
school no one asks you to drive them to
the airport there's this freedom and
everyone just already thinking you're so
batshit crazy
that you wake up at noon and they're
like you woke up and look good
good for you look at you starting your
day early
yeah well emily you woke up in the am 11
59 that's great we're doing am now
that's so great it's weird it's but
there is also i think comedians we're a
little bit the opposite whereas or just
people in general maybe i think the
people that are really going through it
don't talk about it as much like we've
lost friends to where you're like i had
no idea they were going through that
and then they take their life or they
you know i think that for the most part
this is obviously if you're friends or
say they're
struggling help them but i feel like
i've spent so much time giving all my
time and attention to the people they're
like i'm depressed i'm anxious my life
is miserable and i'm like okay and then
the people that actually are going
through real bad they just are quiet i'm
like i how would we have known
you know
kind of thing
so it's like a i don't know that's just
like a weird yeah everyone treats it
differently and i think it's also
generational too like the older people
kind of keep to themselves and the
younger people is like i'm not so alone
you shouldn't be so alone out there
um i
this is so stupid
um
hey hooker
you know that's a blondes that's what
blondes call brunettes hey hooker you're
so cool
um
what all my blonde friends call me like
hey slut i'm like
cool it's like we're taking the word
back i know yeah
we were owning it but like hooker was a
word that i feel like you're supposed to
say prostitute now
yeah so if someone calls me hooker
they're saying you're old no they don't
it's okay that's another angle too i had
one time where it's uh
we're like in a post-shame society i go
back in the day you could make a lot of
money by having sex with random guys for
cash but the downside was you had to be
called a prostitute like that was part
of it so you just had to have that label
now you you're called a sex worker
so it's like none of the shame all of
them
sex doesn't work for the people that
don't get paid for it
sex is work when it's consensual in your
own sure but it's funny just like the
perception around it has completely
changed so you'll be at a party or
something like this is a this is a
dentist there's a cardiovascular
cardiologist uh this is uh denise denise
what do you do i'm a sex worker like oh
that's fantastic
it's totally integrated into society and
it's not this like shameful thing
anymore but is there any other job where
worker is not like woodworker it also
has like when the word workers in it it
has more like like jesus was a
woodworker
he hung out with sex workers it adds
like a little bit of
uh
integrity
yes like uh what else is furniture no
where i work with furniture
i work with or um it's soon it's gonna
be you know like i work with
underprivileged kids i work with kids on
the spectrum like i work with men that
need sex yeah
it's almost like they work with
adulterers the the title is so
churched up and glossy now the like i
could introduce her to my parents be
like well no cindy she's a sex worker so
that's that's her prostitute i like
there was i love two like two two like
the end of it
prostitute
like i just think prostitute is such a
cute word like um to me they all like i
found little tutus
but how do prostitutes and sex workers
how do they insult each other like
like we like girls like hey hooker hey
slut are prostitutes like hey hey
secretary secretary
hey secretary
hey com okay open my comic
[Laughter]
wait what is this do you ever write
things down and you're like what what oh
yeah what was i thinking well the words
we can't say now
um
long time no see you can't say that
anymore you can't well someone was like
a long time no see it's insulting to
like people with broken english like
someone's like it's insulting to chinese
people and i was like i think it's
insulting to blind people
also i love the economy of that joke too
whenever you get jokes that are that
tight and quick i love those because
they're a great way to like open a
little bit just
you can tell this joke to your friend
like i always go can someone repeat this
joke to someone else without fucking it
up yeah it's like a foolproof joke oh
this is so stupid uh
whatever homeless you're supposed to say
temporarily unhoused for real yeah but
that's so verbose i feel like homeless
people are like no this is permanent uh
can you please help me i'm homeless
we're like oh no this is just temporary
they're like
no it's not it's been 20 years it's been
a while
i had this joke where i was like the
homeless problem you know in la and
austin when i was out there too there
was a homeless problem no they were
camping well here's the thing i go like
people are trying to figure out what's
the solution it's really hard topic like
how do we crack this thing i go i want
to know
who's selling the tents
you know like that's the root of the
problem i think like when you buy a tent
at rei you should have to show your
linkedin profile
it's like buying a gun they go okay okay
five years you've worked at this company
all right getting tents you're either
it's like a horse you're either really
rich or really poor
yeah there's no one in between like if
you have a horse you either use it for
transportation
or just to show how pretty it is same
with tents when someone comes in they're
either it's either like
bezos who's going camping in montana to
go off the grid or someone who's like
i'm gonna live in this
and it's almost the same
profiling as you would do for terrorists
like all right he has a beard
i don't know
like a land terrorist
this is like my most favorite thing to
do oh just bouncing bits yeah just like
but like premises yeah oh there's
something funny here dating a younger
guy has made me overly confident
like i used to be so insecure about my
body but now i'm dating a younger guy
and instead of thinking like oh maybe he
just has like likes older women or like
needs his loans paid off i'm like i must
be fucking hot
then i used like the older i get the
hotter i i the older i get the more i
think
like the like it's not bad just more
it's like age just more feel like i
think i look 20 now like i'm just like
i'm like i'm like go to a bar i'm like
you see my id they're like no like just
anything that i have like all this
confidence that i didn't have before um
and it's not a compliment when a younger
guy wants to date an older woman it's
just that once you get wrinkles like
everything is a possible vagina for them
so they just see older women as like
they're turned on all the time every
time i turn my neck he just sees three
possible things to fuck she's covered in
vaginas i love it
like i've got like as you get older you
get more like armpits so many
opportunities yes it's like for me all
these like wrinkles that i try to hide
from him he's like
they just look like pussies like babe
promise me something just never get
botox
i swear i can't just fuck a dolphin
i need the rings don't tell about gills
um i did uh in a show that i did that we
adapted super said true love story by
gary steiner
he's a brilliant satirical
writer and like futurist person and he
said that the uh next generation uh like
of parents and people in their 20s now
they will
you'll be able to choose the eye color
if you want of your kids you're also
going to be able to choose to give your
child gills
what why because we're gonna be like
under what coastal cities like will be
underwater in our lifetime do you think
that'll be a cool thing like it's spring
break where devon's taking his shirt off
and she's like oh my god you got the
gill package
yeah my parents sprung for it check this
out
oh my god he's so fucking fast
bryce you can't cut through the water
like that my parents couldn't afford
goons
i'm i'm leaving you
[Laughter]
also where's my ring oh it's in my guess
what if he like runs out on her just
like leaves like walks
into the ocean like it's not working out
for me
for a dolphin yeah yeah see ya damn it
yeah i'm gonna go hit you right on a
carnival cruise
are you doing any
like
relaxing or hobbies
uh i'm trying to get better you know but
i don't need a lot i take simple
pleasure but here's what i'm realizing i
think as comedians we really like i feel
like we're such workaholics and we're
such comedians 24 7. and i was talking
to some i was watching i can't tell if i
had a conversation listen to a podcast
or read a book or it was a
dream i'm barely here but what i will do
is if i listen to a podcast or watch a
documentary i'm like i was reading this
book the other day like it was not a
book i have no idea i go i was in the
cockpit trying to do this mission the
other day with rooster and
tom cruise was trying to get me to do
this track in three minutes and it was
really hard pushing um like i have no
idea val kilmer was there and
oh like i am
so unclear if what happened to me
yesterday if it was someone else's ig
live i will appropriate other people's
experiences like the other day when i
was in italy and i'm like that didn't
happen to me like you know like i'm just
passing this story i don't know where i
heard it but like
i don't i don't know where i what was
that so it's important to take breaks or
vacations in order to be a good writer
oh it was ryan holiday um in order to be
a good writer you have to lead an
interesting life and i think for me i'm
always like okay i have to wake up at
you know
1 15 just kidding in order to be an
interesting writer you have to lead an
interesting life and i was like that is
so fucking true and i just feel like the
onus is on us to like live a little more
yeah yeah totally i i subscribe to all
that and what are you doing what are
your hobbies um i love music i like
what is that too low like playing it or
just listening to listening can i run
something about you sure
maybe this is a bit for that i think you
would be amazing at like
would you go to a listening party
it depends how well you please do an
impression of a guy at the listening
party who really wants the artist to
know he likes it
all right so so do we know the artist
but here's the other thing about
listening party you know none of the
words because it's a new song
what's worse than listening to a song
you don't never heard before it'd be so
funny if the guy is trying to get on the
artist's good side but trying to pretend
to sing along to a song that hasn't even
come out yet or just like
no but like it's almost like it's like
garth and cat like
like you know the end you can get
baby baby baby
you hear the chorus once baby baby
you're the best baby baby baby wait two
babies who doesn't put a third baby and
there's like baby it gets quiet
yeah how do you how do you sit at a
listening party you can't be too but do
you make you can't look at people
no yeah you gotta be in your own world i
think you gotta be on the edge of your
seat a little bit like you're
anticipating this listening party but
you can't like then you gotta be in your
own little world a little bit to me a
listening party is worse than like an
orgy
like it's so much more like the idea of
just i would close my eyes
and just like take fake notes like amber
heard did in her trial i would just be
like scribbling on a piece of paper like
she dressed like a judge thinking she
would get like better
treatment or opinion-wise if i look like
a judge she dressed like a mennonite
like priestess
right she looked like an amish milkmaid
from the head up
and then from the neck down
dressed like a like a handmaid who just
got to canada and like got to make their
case but they had to make their clothes
out of like curtains and old
military uniforms yeah did you see the
day where she dressed exactly like dr
evil
oh my god what it was so
fucking funny
taking a break break break taking a
break
break
break big break we've stopped saying
in the beginning
yeah that is annoying when someone else
does it is it that annoying when i do it
[Laughter]
life's a nightmare it's time to drink
wine
hot or not read the news everyone needs
a cool glass of grape juice
that's been in a cellar it's been
fermented 100 years yeah it's a rough
time it's a rough time now did you know
literal sour grapes that summer heat and
sunlight can spoil your wine and your
good times if it's not properly stored
yeah tell me about it so now's the time
to get those bottles off the countertops
and protect them with a wine fridge from
wine enthusiasts get your wine
out of the glove compartment get it out
of the closet where you my mom used to
keep a wine opener in her glove
compartment and um she told me it was
for her tires but it when as i got older
i was like that's a wine bottle opener
for my for parenting it's because i'm
tired of you
of your whining yeah so what i'm saying
is i am just realizing the
delights
of a little vino um at the end of the
day she's only a thousand years later
she's like have you guys heard of this
new thing called wine you guys it's
delicious and
i guess when you grow up with so many
stepmoms drinking something you're like
oh that's bad
i was like ah that makes dad not like me
as much you know what i mean yeah but
then you're like ah this makes me like
me a ton
okay so i am so into wine right now it's
there it's just there's no i guess that
now i get why i get wine now guys
you know what this business should stick
around wine i think this is gonna stick
i think this is this idea is gonna take
wine enthusiasts designs and offers the
largest selection of wine coolers for
every drinker every budget and every
size collection from six to six hundred
bottles but do you know that everyone's
storing their wine wrong and if you do
have questions there are expert wine
storage consultants available by phone
to help you find the right fit for all
your needs wine enthusiast is the
premiere destination for the wine
lifestyle offering an incredible
selection of unique wine accessories
glassware furniture wine storage gifts
and more visit wine enthusiasts dot com
or text the code gfy2515511
remember text gfy to 511 511 today to
check out all of the wine enthusiasts
summer savings text gfy to 11 5 11 today
certain exclusions may apply you may
receive up to one additional text
text fees may apply text stop to opt out
i'll tell you what i'm not going to opt
out of
coming to see you live
you're going to come see me in ohio
yeah at the taft theater it's weird i
was touring when i was going to austin
miami san francisco everyone wants to
come
now i'm going to cincinnati philly
radio silence from everyone here at the
good for you
team no yeah just call me about those
london dates next
no one seems to want to come on tour
with me
anymore people were really chomping at
the bitch they were chomping at the bit
charleston nashville miami austin yeah
now i'm like hey guys
sorry
i'm going to toledo they're like
mailer damon
unsubscribe september
september 8th i will be in cincinnati
ohio taft theater september 9th i'll be
in philadelphia pennsylvania at the
miriam theater and then i am going to be
in richmond september 10th uh richmond
virginia at the national this is gonna
be all new jokes too by the way
september 24th i'll be in
charlottesville virginia uh the
paramount theater come see me make fun
of emily for a full hour
back to our gear i always thought about
doing a podcast where it's called it's
just it's called this has been a date
and it's like just super hot chicks and
they have no idea at the very end you'll
thank you this has been a date by the
way so you're just bamboozling hot
chicks to be on this podcast but it's
really just a date i mean every meeting
with every agent i had in my 20s where
you realize you know when you realize
halfway through you're hanging out with
someone you realize it's a date and
you're like how stupid
i am stupid or i just see myself as so
disgusting it would never occur to me
that this person wanted i'm such a
i'm so um
dysmorphic about that stuff like people
will say all the time they're like oh
when you used to date so-and-so and i
was like
no we're like buddies what are you
talking about they're like oh and i'm
like oh we dated like i just thought we
were hanging out
he just thought he was dating you for
five years not having sex
you know she's taking it really slow
we're we just want to be friends first
for the first five years and then we
don't want to rush it
and it gives me something to look
forward to and uh i fell in love with
her soul
and um
like i see her dating other guys too and
i'm like look at how strong we are yeah
she wants to be sure when she picks me
and i like that can we talk about
polyamory
yeah and how it's just are we pretending
this isn't cheating are we pretending
that two people are actually on the same
page ever
one person is brokenhearted and crying
in kroger
right and i think people everyone's
going to be at a different level in that
relationship of investment and what they
think it is if you started as polyamory
okay
if you've been together for two years
and you're like i think we should be
polyamory how many polyamory success
stories do you hear
ironically
one
joking uh i i i feel like there's this
cause someone the other day
there's um like a
instagram like
healer type person
who is in a like throuple
and i took the person really seriously
and it's like anyway so we've just added
a third to our relationship and we're
down in like a thrupp and i was like
i'm done
i'm done with you i'm not taking advice
from you on how to make a relationship
work if you were just like ah
well his advice is only good for three
he's like i'm sorry i thought it was for
two but this is for the thruffles this
is throuple advice i don't yeah like i
don't no wonder i was buying so many
groceries uh do they do therapy like
couples throughput therapy and there's
three people on the couch and the the
therapist is just like buy a van
we're like i don't know who sits in the
front a throuple would be so stressful i
would literally be like who sits in the
front seat do you have to go shotgun
like it's little things like that
because the world is designed for two
people like if you're in a throuple and
you like go to six flags like who sits
next to who are like there's always
gonna be a third wheel like in the back
at magic mountain like in the picture
like like trying to get in
what about add another dude then it's
even teams
then you're in a quad whatever double
dating
i'm not a did you see the mormon
documentary what's it called everyone uh
dude over the under the banner of heaven
oh what's it on uh it's on amazon prime
no it's hulu
it's it's andrew garfield
you know you'll find it okay all right
you don't care where it is i kind of do
you go go you look see this drives me
nuts this drives me a little bit nuts so
you know my number one pet peeve is when
someone asks you a question they could
google
and i'm the asshole i was like this
feels like a question for google do you
ever have that where you get someone on
the list they go hey i want to come to
your show and you put them on the list
you're on the list and it doesn't end
there then it's like what time should i
get there where do i park
uh i'm in line can you come and get me
hey crazy day
i don't think i'm gonna make it after
all after you already i wouldn't have
noticed yeah
it is and then this is my uh drives me
insane when people are like i want to
come to your show you're like cool come
in i just look at my twitter no and they
see you again hey i am
i'm i've been slammed i am dying to see
i'm like i'm going to come soon i'm
going to go i really care i don't know
with or without like i'm really not
dying to cop you for a show that i then
have to babysit you for
and then they have to be like i'm and
then your relationship is awkward every
time you see them they're like
i am coming
i
swear the kid has been sick i uh and i'm
you're like you're making this weird
yeah i don't need this from you i don't
need your fandom i don't need you to see
you come if you want to come that's okay
like imagine me
being disappointed you haven't come to
see a show but i did see you on stage
one time and you had a single tear come
down when you saw that empty chair
that was reserved it's like where is
rita um what else is in the news yeah
this person i kind of know from work
didn't make it like i don't want you to
come i'm gonna make fun of you and
you're gonna know it's about you one
step beyond that is when you're at a
party or something and the guy's like
uh oh yeah i wanna come like tell me
tell me next time you're performing so
now it's on me to tell this stranger
i'm gonna hey what's your number hey
doug it's me from the party remember i'm
i'm blake's friend
i'm performing tuesday if you're free oh
that doesn't work for you um well what
about uh wednesday i have a show i have
two shows that doesn't work either by
the way there's 500 other people coming
to the show that got there yes they all
figured it out they paid they paid
it's been booked for months this thing
like we're so far in our careers where
we don't need to put bodies and seats
like we're open mikers i need to fill a
room if you're a one or two-year comic
that let me know when you're performing
makes sense because you got to be like
hey i'm having a show and i need to
bring people to get stage time because
that's a thing early on
but when you're a seasoned comedian and
someone's like tell me the next time
you're performing netflix now yeah just
go on youtube you can see me whenever
you want i don't care so much that this
for the stranger to come and see me i
don't need that no good deed
no good indeed you just want it to end
there i'm at the point where i'm like
live learn it never ends there
it never ends there like i now have a
couple friends where i am just their
like concierge on call
dog person
they're like hey can you look into this
picture of this mole i'm like i stopped
sending me photos of your dog's balls i
don't i literally gave you the number
one one number that's where it ends
like how uh do you not know to google
this yeah but how did i get annoyed at
that i just wanted to know the streaming
service
well excuse me ma'am i just wanted to
know because
because i don't think you really care i
think i don't think you care
i think you were just doing an
impression of a small talk which
comedians do i do that too where someone
will be like i'll be oh what's it on
what is that what do you mean i actually
just wanted to remove the one step of
googling
but i just mean i think people ask that
and you're adding work to me i was just
trying to give you a show to watch and
now you're making me be like
now i look dumb there's certain things
where i think people think i just think
it's funny when people do things by
accident like when you're just trying to
because small talk is my number one like
i ca i'm not good at it i don't like it
it feels like work to me i want to go i
don't want to be like hey how was the
traffic i want to go straight into like
what's your biggest fear what what
antidepressants are you on yeah
yeah
scarf scarf what was the brand like i
want to get into it so when i'm already
making small talk i already don't want
to do this and now you're making me like
be like what streamer and i have to like
be like man i think it was hulu maybe
but hulu and amazon merge wait hold on
no it's paramount plus but paramount's
technically owned by hbo mac so you
could see it on no one knows what
anything's on yeah you know no one no i
don't even know what streamers are still
out there
yeah what is out there cecil's gone that
stuff because now what you on apple tv
i'll just put in the name of the show
and it'll come up and i don't know where
it is it could be fucking al jazeera for
all i know
there's this great new drama on al
jazeera it's it's like yeah you know why
is this this is what's funny about that
exchange you did none of this but i'm
just projecting
hold on so is this so so if i haven't
seen something i get insecure so ask me
if i've seen a show uh
have you have you watched shrill
no what's it on
the what's it on is like
if i haven't
like it must be on some bozo
like it's so channel the way you're
projecting because like
that that's not even on my radar
whatsoever like when you said what's it
on i'm like oh she's inquisitive she
wants to find out she wants to watch it
and remove a step no i now because i
move through the world always worried
like people think i'm crazy or stupid
and i have this thing where i feel like
i have to know everything all the time
so when i haven't seen something i've
already i haven't seen this character
doesn't like me like what's it on like
like you threw this elitist angle of
like or no i'm like i i just watched
this show under the banner of ever
heaven what's it on like you're like i
might be lying like you think i'm lying
you're like danny you're like low stakes
danny devito or not that uh joe peggy
but what's it on there
but it's like i want if i had missed out
how come i haven't seen it what's it on
like there's something so like
like you're doubting that it exists or
something do you think that if it was
like a worthy streamer i would have seen
it and this streamer must be so subpar i
have to be like what's it on do they air
it on the four seasons network i don't
where i watch hulu
i only do discovery plus what is so
funny to me because there is like so
many serious document r so many serious
documentaries out there and you're like
i just watched this documentary about
abortion uh in laos what's it on hulu
yeah i had this fucked up
yeah i was watching the epstein dock on
netflix
and it's it's so fucked up where i'm
like i wanted it to keep going
you know obviously you don't want that
atrocities to happen yeah but you're
like i wish there was more
than going on ten more years yeah
maybe maybe he turned it around that was
the same thing with elizabeth holmes i
was like what if you guys have just
given her a little more time here's what
i can't understand and can't believe is
that after all of that crazy shit and
bilking all the money for people or the
people for money and all that and the
bamboozling a guy still marries her like
yeah she's still great you know but you
know but super rich guy yeah let me say
two what is that let me say two things
number one you know that she married uh
the guy whose family owns torrey pines
in la jolla
and the family is just cool like you
know she tried to start up it didn't
like oh fuck he found a blonde girl
ah
the future throne will be blind
and like hitler would have liked her
like what but um uh also
this is a thing that girls
ha i believe emily you tell me this show
guys when they
they date date date date you know i
liked her why did like all my guy
friends stay
once they pick or your exes
the one they pick is always whack
it's always like elizabeth it's always
like why her
like of all i'm not saying i'm that
great but like when guys have like lots
of like bachelory guys and then you're
like that's the one you went with
we always feel like the way you feel
about that guy in elizabeth holmes we
always feel about the girls you guys
marry we're like that's the one you
chose
the one that like berates you in the
hallway like we now we all have to you
why did you pick because then you're
like oh some guys just need like a mom
or like a like a lot of times i find
guys
who dated a lot of women maybe it's just
because they're they needed someone to
just
end up with the woman who was just like
the most controlling over them that was
just like here's what's going to happen
you're going to fucking like the ways
that i always learn you're never allowed
to behave i find like some guys need
that yeah they respond like fire this
person fire this person you're going
here like your name is mitch now and
you're like
what
like you know what i mean like someone
who's maybe just gonna like solve shit
which actually maybe is cool because
it's even more annoying when i see my
guy friends dating girls that are like
she doesn't drive you're like what are
you doing
why are you dating a mess like is this
hot to you that you have to like rescue
this like wounded bird yeah you used to
be your uber everywhere i know like i
know a guy friends of mine where i'm
like they'll be like oh i have to i
can't come over today my girlfriend got
lost at the mall i'm like what
how old is she
she got lost in the american doll
the american girl store
hey where am i
i'm in the chinese doll section i can't
i took a left and did you see the
abercrombie and fetch documentary no oh
my gosh it is
[Laughter]
i mean fitch.net i don't know yeah yeah
they're doing their new streaming
services
because it's like
it makes me face the fact that i don't
know something yeah and i'm like i
should know and it's embarrassing when i
just watched six hours of a documentary
and couldn't tell you what i watched it
on
that just is very tells a lot about me
like i saw this documentary it's like
really fucked up with what happened what
happened i don't know but i just know
that it was i don't know where to watch
it i don't know who made it i'm not
entirely sure it happened i could have
just dreamt this but here's the yeah but
i ate a lot of lunches through the stuff
that i saw i think it's also a way to
stay engaged in a conversation and look
cool someone's like ah dude have you
seen ozark what's it on
like you think you're gonna fucking be
in charge of this combo i'm gonna throw
i'm gonna throw you a little and then
cause it flusters people what's it on um
what's the noise of the network you
could power we would say tv
roku yeah like it's just sort of like
roku imdb the streaming service now it's
like there's a new one every morning how
am i supposed to that would be funny if
like all i had was discovery plus and i
had a date and i'm like alright scott i
gotta go upstairs or whatever just you
can fire up the tv i got discovery plus
do you have anything else no i just i
watch discovery plus like that's all i
watch really
you don't have netflix no discovery and
chill yeah but there's like um plus and
chill plus and chill
there's something about like what is
even on roku and chill like what yeah
but the fact that that got so big when
it's
literally a catchphrase about like
fucking right like you're we're gonna
trick the girl you're with into we're
gonna give you enough time to get her
drunk well you're gonna watch this movie
and then you're gonna chill
like if you wan the people that watch
netflix fuck
like what a genius way to market
something yeah netflix and fuck would be
too abrasive i know i was who was i was
talking about over there the fact that
they haven't launched a porn section
called netflix
netflix
or netflix xxx i love thinking of names
of
things there used to be a
place it was called
adam and weave it was a weave store and
talent agency what
it's on the bread i swear to god in
wilshire it's a combo it's like a pizza
hot taco bell exactly right agency and
weave place
weaves and talent agency if you are a
client like talent
and you
go by all these wigs or you're passing
them on the way to talk to your agent
how do you feel about your career but
it's good you're able to be like look if
the hair color is bumping you
it's a great place to be like don't
please don't let what's on my head
distract you because we can change that
do you think there's conflict of
interest or the agents just suggesting
weaves that she needs to buy if you want
to make it in the biz your hair's
holding you back the americans over here
at some point will have to do you feel
like when you were auditioning or like
like
do you feel like you were ever in a
situation where you're like this is
racist
like this is like i don't want to i i
if someone else does this job great but
i don't want to do this
yeah yeah and you can kind of combat
that with just the jobs that you choose
to go out for and you tell your people
what is on brand for you and what you're
trying to do and what what is not on
brand and what you don't want to do
and i'm not knocking any that's because
there's a marketplace some stories need
to get told and actors
want to act and they just want to
service those roles and be a vessel but
we're stand-up comedians you know i'm a
stand-up comedian first and foremost
where are we on if you're if you're
asian if you're when the asian is an
account it's like japanese play japanese
chinese play chinese you know like are
you ever like i'm not greek man i'm
telling you uh the first acting thing i
ever did i auditioned for chuck you know
that show on nbc so now i got this like
huge guest star so
it's actually it was the role was from
manush deepak which is indian
but a lot of times in hollywood they'll
just
choose a race for this role and it's
pretty loose so you'll see different
types of
middle eastern and south asian people
just go out for the same thing even if
it says pakistani they're not married to
the idea that it's pakistani yeah unless
it's integral to the storyline and a lot
of times it's not
so exactly yeah so you can slide in it's
not like this would make no sense yes
there wasn't there wasn't mention of
manufak's
heritage in the script is yeah so i got
the role of manooche deepak even though
i'm not indian yeah and i people aren't
like he's not indian yeah like it's not
there's not enough attention on it
exactly it's like i don't yeah exactly
if you're not
specifically
it's not black panther and they cast yes
that's exactly it it's like it's like
it's just kind of like that that is kind
of my thing on it's like this isn't a
big enough
part of the his the culture and the
backstory isn't enough for it to be
offensive to you mm-hmm they just were
like we want someone who's not white
we'll figure out later yeah and it's not
high profile enough to
but if we get back we'll make sure it's
all attention to this person but then
you it does get tricky it's like i know
bill burr you know did a thing about
this where he's like
if someone that's not handicap is
playing handicap like that's acting yeah
whereas it's like well we need to hire a
handicapped person well that's a
documentary and then yeah totally and
then you also run into this intersection
of art and commerce
these conversations are so fun to me
like even if we're like wrong and none
of this should be
implemented it's like we should be able
to go like
yeah that was like a funny way to look
at it
people like think comedians should be
our our job is to have like bad takes
well we just take swings that's part of
it too like uh yeah risks and you don't
know there are plenty of times you have
a like a hot take on something or
because we push it a little bit
occasionally and the audience will let
you know when you're wrong and it's
humbling yeah and you need that
sometimes and it helps you refine the
joke and make the idea a little more
crystalline
or even educate you where you're like oh
i'm wrong on this that's the wrong way
what's wrong with
people that are wrong sometimes like
there's just this like like we've
forgotten it's okay to be wrong if
you're don't have information or don't
have an experience that would lead you
like my thing is if someone's wrong i'm
like oh given the circumstances why
would they know any different or given
that they're like that used to be right
and now it's wrong all of a sudden and
some people are gonna have to catch up
like the idea that we're there's this
like
schism
you just bring it back
that is like
you're wrong you're trash you're dead to
me when someone's wrong i'm like i want
to hear that person talk yeah
this is going to be interesting or funny
if nothing else you know and like it's
like your like most backward uncle you
know like sometimes comedians are just
like your silly uncle that you maybe
don't take
voting advice from but like you
definitely want to hear his take sure on
marianne williamson
like who the what the fuck is going on
here you know what i mean like i i don't
know i just
i feel like
in this podcast i guess i'm trying to do
because i have no idea what to do on a
podcast it's trying to have all these
conversations that most people like have
like this right because most people are
just trying to catch up to look at a
second i'm totally fine for only
handicapped people to play handicapped
parts but
like just to be able to it's like
everyone is running for office nowadays
interesting just every conversation even
just everyone is so worried and there's
a lot of stress so i think that's why
comedy is bigger than it's ever been you
know what i love there's that moment
because we do so many shows and stuff
and occasionally you'll have someone
who's a heckler being disruptive
and they think the audience is on their
side and there's that moment where
everyone
looks at them and is like jeering at
them and they find out that like their
whole paradigm has shifted like oh i'm
the bad guy in this movie i thought they
were all they go no everyone hates you
lady
you're ruining yeah ruining the show
they bought tickets six months you just
ruined someone's prom it's nice to give
someone that moment normally i will have
fun with it because most of the time
they are just a little drunk and they're
having a good time and they mean well
yeah so their intention is still good
and pure but i get drunk
bars i get drunk plenty of places and it
never occurs to me to yell at the person
working some people are different people
are tipsy in different ways but if they
are if they have a good soul and they're
just being i can i can manage it and
still have i can roll with it and improv
but sometimes they're mean and malicious
and that's when you the crowd wants you
to lay into them and i actually think
that's better because it's clear what's
going on when someone's a helpful
heckler that's worse because they're
being they're they truly and i think in
the age of podcasts i'm really trying to
navigate like how i change the way i
perform
as if someone has like heard us talk for
three hours that week you already know
me well like you you can't get away with
as much but like i you know comedians we
like to be like so anyway uh last week i
was you know in new york and they're
like no you weren't
no you were in florida last week i
thought with your aunt wait what and
then you're like shit man like i can't
just be vague anymore like they know you
too well i know i'm like anyway so i'm
so clumsy but you played basketball in
high school but you made all those free
throws on your instagram i'm like shit
like i can't eat like yeah
god damn it no yeah you're a super fan
and so a lot of times you get people i
think they're so amped to be there and
i i'm learning that i guess i take a lot
of
pauses to pretend i'm like and it's not
it's not pretend i kind of am like
you're gathering your thoughts
thoughts and i really like i feel like i
spent so much of my career in the
beginning being like
like just yelling at the audience and
like oh and like i was like i'm a
comedian a female comedian i have to be
you know have twice as many jokes and
half the amount like i have to work
twice as hard to get half like people
are so ready to say i'm not funny i have
to like jam in a million jokes in two
seconds and now i like kind of like
chill and um
if it looks like to them i'm trying to
find my words
sometimes they'll be like
yeah when you were um in the the frozen
yogurt place or maybe like and i'm like
no i got it i know i know like i don't i
don't need this but thank you i know
where i'm going believe it or not that's
so sweet like they're trying to help
your train of thought
and also thank you for coming even
though you didn't think i had a plan
they go you got this whitney you're
taking a split second just together you
can do this
the idea will come to you i
get this a lot people like love you
whitney i'm like i'm do you guys think i
have cancer like what are you do you
think it's the first time i've ever done
this or just in the middle of a pause
they're like
i know
come on you can do it you can do it you
you can string the thoughts together
[Laughter]
that was a big breakthrough for me in
stand-up as well like um
learning getting to that point where
you're enough on stage and you're
comfortable being observed and you're
just throwing these ideas out there and
you don't need anything from the
audience because when you first start
there's this eye contact with the crowd
and the crowd feels like this person's
well-being is dependent on me laughing
or not like there's this
uh like umbilical cord between you and
the audience this unspoken contract that
is like i have to honor my
side of this conference the audience can
tell that this person's soul needs these
laughs so bad to be whole and when
someone is needy it's repellent yes that
makes you lean yes but if you're
watching a comic and they're like like
when you watch chappelle or you know
like oh he's got this it's like a pilot
like a very a seasoned pilot yeah it's
it's it's very
um
like
relaxing to be able to watch a comedian
that is like fine with or without you
and
watching the special it was so gangster
to watch because it made me realize like
the the fucked up part about specials is
it's lightning in a bottle like if you
get if if you are able to capture the
electricity that because you know you
said this earlier when we were talking
i don't know why we talked off camera
that was weird
we're like celine dion was like we were
kind of like hate fucking we're like
anyway how was the drive over there
we have the stephen hawking thing
doesn't say our voice we're like hello
whitney how are you things are good all
right we will do the podcast up there
have a water if you want
save your vocal cords
you look nice
though i do kind of miss like
the days as comedians when you would go
in and do radio to promote your shows
and you'd have to like 5 a.m you have to
go do like radio dj's like hey here i am
it's moose in the morning and they see
like hey what's up man and you're like
oh you have to be that person every time
a red light comes on
what a nightmare um all right i'm
obsessed with you i will talk to you i
would talk to you for truly ever thank
you i hope we'll get to yeah we will
patrick here it is
on my youtube special and there's all
these like dreamy
and by the way i thought
even my dude who's not a comedian like
the montagey moments in between like
just getting glimpses of comedians at
the store was so like
it was so cool i don't know i kept
waiting for there to be like me in the
background like in fact you weren't
there that's your position i would have
put you in there if you were there one
of the nicest i just i remember just
being like oh god am i going to be
around the corner being like
like just on with better help like just
like there's a dog licking you while
you're like
oh sorry something i was going to say
really quick about you and um your
career in terms of like the always
writing jokes like the greats i always
see in the hallway like right like i
remember one time um
a tell
he was like
you know in a fucking composite before
like always always new jokes always new
jokes and someone was like chabot what
are you doing and he was like writing
jokes ever heard of it
but i remember just being like even when
you're fucking great
that's like he's working harder than
anyone here and he's the funniest person
here neil brennan has this quote he goes
whoever writes the most jokes wins it's
as simple as that
whoever writes the most jokes and like
he neil said something that blew my mind
too when i
um
you know when you're dealing with a
community when you get like some success
and you start thinking other comedians
don't like you or you're jump you know
you're getting something you don't
deserve or whatever there's like maybe
not so much anymore but like there used
to be so much like jealousy and
negativity and toxicity and like he said
something once or he goes if i was a
talent manager i would walk into a
comedy club and ask the comedians who
they hated
and i would sign that person
and it helped me it was just the perfect
way to put it like who do you hate oh
fuck
let me go sign that guy yeah and it
helped me be like oh yeah it's nothing
personal it's just like means you're
doing well yeah yeah
so everybody hated you yeah yeah yeah so
are you ready for everyone haters this
beloved thing isn't working out for me
you're about to lose a lot of friends
finally
are you touring at all i think i'm
trying to set up some dates in the fall
to take advantage of this and yeah so
i'll try to do some cities in the fall
really quick really quick sorry we
always do this i just i'm genuinely you
are so funny to me i genuinely want to
know
any like red flags
in people or like girls like what is
annoying to guys about girls right now
like what's a red flag uh i think maybe
because of the prevalence of dating amps
is that everything is so fleeting and
nothing is this concrete anymore maybe
the next thing is always right there so
maybe it's harder to have someone on the
hook and not have their eye on something
else
i think that
say it again a different way uh just
because there are so many options with
bumble tinder raya
that
you know being committed to someone for
a length of time is a bit harder than
maybe in the past okay yes yes oh yeah
because you know there's it's like
something better it's door number three
three girls in town yes you knew what
your options were now it's like i'm
unlimited i don't know who knows what
i'm passing on this could be good but
something could be better
i feel like people have always thought
that way well without apps because it
remember there was a time when meeting
that way was kind of you wouldn't tell
anybody you met on
online before apps just all thought they
had a chance with a celebrity
like guys will come up to me they'll be
like
like uh you're my hall pass
and i'm like so do i have to fuck you
now yeah i have to my wife yeah yes my
women will be like you're my husband's
hall pass i'm like why is he looking for
other women to f like why does that is
that fair i always have to stop because
like sometimes women will have this um
this fantasy like uh if
ryan gosling if he you know if we hit it
off or something that he's going to be
this consummate gentleman
the guy who has a million options in the
world is going to treat you like beauty
and the beast or something
when in reality this guy is
his dm's are flooded he's fucking ryan
gosling it would be an experience
because your fantasy is like your you
know bell but in reality it'd be the dm
like hey you're hot here's my address
and then he's in bed and he's like i'm
gonna send to uber for you and when you
meet gosling he's like literally naked
under the sheets doesn't even greet you
it was an overpower yeah he's in a
mansion he's like you're gonna go up the
stairs you're gonna pass the vase take a
right there's an nda on the dresser sign
it and then hop into the bed when i one
time when i first moved to la
dated like a famous musician and
i uh he was like let's hang i'm like
cool
nine o'clock he's just texting me his
address
and writes take fountain
that was it and then i had to like
figure it out yeah the rest of it and
you're like that this is the most it's
insane but i think that the romantic
comedies in like the notebook and stuff
like that that is porn for women yeah i
will also say conversely
in porn women watch more and we're like
um
women don't come after 10 seconds but
okay
like we have to live with these
unrealistic expectations that guys have
of women i just love like i love a cut
and dry rule that is always true and
there's less and less anymore uh
not everyone lives by this but in the
entertainment industry i like the
concept of one headshot per couple
that's not my quote i think it might
have been uh
maybe ari or someone in the store had
that quote
i don't even get oh i see one how about
one podcast per couple sure that i'm
gonna do you if you both have a podcast
i'm doing one i don't have to do both of
your podcasts yeah but just the two
entertainers thing is hard to make it
work like i already feel like i'm a
vampire literally okay i am so dumb i
thought you meant like you both have to
be in the same headshot
wait i still think that oh i thought
that's what you meant like a
be a duo i mean like only one of you
could be doing hollywood shit that's not
what i thought he meant like a selfie of
both of you me too you're a package
dealer like natasha legere motion
catcher you're in the same 8x10 like you
can't even be separate people in the
business like you're a
together you can only have one before
i'm i'm i agree
there's exceptions i i i know there's
plenty of things i just never want
people to say to me like ah candidate
comedian because like all of those like
like rules i sometimes find myself going
like well i'd be the one to get fucked
if i
implemented that rule don't i mean like
they're usually always
uh
yeah um
i agree but i don't want it to be true
how about that right
that's a rule for me just like you
shouldn't not date someone just because
they have a stupid dream
yeah
and also if they're successful
it's it's if someone's aspiring
and someone's not that's always going to
be rough you need to be in the same
place well i like that both people have
a north star that they are whether it's
okay i have comedy and these pursuits
and all that but if they love this
charity work or they love
their company that they work out and
they want to you know increase the
portfolio or something like yeah that's
attractive just purpose
it's tricky it's like i my thing with
that is if you're a woman dating an
actor just be ready to see him in makeup
because it'll happen and you'll have to
fuck him again yeah
he will come home one day in a full
shellacked
you think there's people who like barely
work and they keep the makeup on just to
prove like
i i got a gig i did a job i liked it no
i like the idea that guys do that be it
where's the caller still like hey guys
oh yeah i guess i was doing a bisco
shoot
here's what's funny about it is that i
think
hold on this is
so
fucking funny to me which is it
i think guys think that makeup is
invisible
so so if a guy's like i'll just go
straight to the bar from work we're like
why are you wearing makeup he's like you
can see this i've done that
because i don't see it i don't girls see
it like we i know you're wearing makeup
and i think guys shocked you can see the
makeup i'm like yeah yes of course like
it's not you're not
floating through space invisible like
when you're in i when you're in
camouflage i can also see your body in
your legs like i can see you
i know you're wearing makeup yeah i've
done that before go from a shoot to
doing the comedy store and i wonder if
people thought like this guy have stage
makeup on like this guy cares enough
about stand up they'll be like is it
showtime
is it a comedian or is it a cake yeah
just to make it that precious for every
set like
they're gonna love you talk about
ralph's talk about avocados and apples
relationships
you're a star
for 15 minutes i do that every night
that's what's crazy about this because
like you see us talking to the comics
and then we hop in and do a room of 300
people and then we talk to our friends
stop pretending we're that different
than clowns
we are we're glad we're literally clowns
with no makeup i remember i i was doing
uh
naca you ever do neca were you doing
college exactly
you explain it so neca is where is this
conference for entertainment it's where
all the schools go to to book their
entertainment for the year so comedians
will go and do their sets and
representatives from the colleges will
be there which means students students a
lot of times the students it's it's and
a lot of times most of the money comes
from like religious groups it's the
students on campus that like have their
you know get to pick who's gonna be at
homecoming and stuff like that they have
all the power and they're like 21. and
they have so much money yeah and it
exists in case they can't get aziz
ansari uh yeah yeah they'll pick one of
us and you have to be clean you have to
like there's so many boxes you have to
check in order to get booked there and
you're doing comedy to try to get as
many bookings as possible it's not
exactly art it's it's mostly commerce
you know i would stand in a booth
holding headshots yeah so then you're at
a booth there's this aftermarket this
marketplace afterwards and this is when
it was kind of a rude awakening of where
we are in the pantheon of entertainment
and all that so everyone has different
booths and it's not just comics there's
other forms of entertainment oh
magicians
yeah so i'm in a booth and there's a guy
you know who's uh selling sumo suits to
schools so he'll come to your school and
set up sumo suits snooki will do a
personal appearance and then when you're
in that bazaar you go oh that uh i'm a
clown i am a carnie i am a carny yeah
i'm a carnage i am assuming it's between
me and a sumo suit it's between me and a
guy who like juggles fire right
that's what we do we're we're jugglers
so it was refreshing it was a night
sometimes you need to be brought back
down but that's the other thing when
people like how come you're not using
platform response i'm like dude i'm in
the same echelon
as mime
yeah as like street performer
like i'm in the same echelon as like
snake the guy at this with the snake
down at the boardwalk i was talking to
roy wood jr about just like stand-up and
stuff and he goes
uh if you look on spotify stand-up
comedy is listed under jazz
because we're in it and we put so much
importance on this thing but it was such
a great bird's eye view to be like oh
yeah it's not as big these feelings i'm
having about it i can love it but in the
grand scheme of things it's below jazz
it's people improvising music
is more valuable than our written jokes
that we planned out
jazz you're like oh they're just gonna
make it up on the flag
we're like i worked on this for a year
and i stand by it
it and if you don't like it like you
don't support free speech yeah that's
what's funny to me that we're like you
every comment i was like free speech and
then they tell a shitty joke that bombs
are like you don't sport free speech
like no that was just nice no i support
jokes i
a speech that makes me involuntarily
laugh like i'm allowed to not think
you're funny why is that a violation of
the first amendment
you're bombing i don't know what to tell
you we've all been quiet for an hour
you've talked the whole time you have
plenty of free speech yeah an hour is so
long to go bombing it is so oh um a
minute feels like an eternity with no
laughs i will go less hard if i'm
getting less from the other
joke that's like
the uh where i have to hang glide and my
belly's on the stool
like it's hard to rain that in there's
like a tiny hazelnut it's just like you
know it would look like this or you know
how it is like i'm not gonna have
bacteria
[Laughter]
like when you just like this last hour i
just did is so physical and i'm like if
this bombs i took such a big fish i'm
literally on the floor i'm like if this
bombs i have to stand up when it's quiet
oh my god imagine you like bombing the
whole time and you just know like i have
to do the worm in a minute
you guys think that was awkward are you
just dreading it you're like nothing is
working
i'm gonna have to do the worm in about a
minute
to fuck
well maybe i'll get him with the worm
and then cut to mid worm and it's like
still silent
i'm telling you i did a joke i was like
on the ground and if i didn't get up
fast enough it wouldn't get like it
wasn't going well it'd be so quiet like
um
okay here we go like you have to like
regroup
god damn it that's why i think it's
important i'm realizing more and more
like to to have some silences you put it
on purpose so if one comes by accident
you can just make it one of your things
you know this is just me in the pocket
yeah it's like this is just me like i've
done this the whole time you know i've
just been collecting my thoughts for
five minutes this is one of those those
quiet moments that i'm so known for
you just like lean into it
i love you i love you too and these are
very awkwardly very excited let's do it
again for sure and um
check out the special thank you for
having me
just jokes on youtube don't be ass no no
that's yours that's yours mine's hat
trick
this is when the blood sugar starts
plummeting you guys um
then you do the rest don't red elephants
ow i just pinched myself no
oh
you'll be okay are you bleeding pee on
it yeah i don't know
um uh
it's on this thing they got it they got
it
youtube i'm not gonna beg you i'm not
gonna be needy about it
to what just when you watch it watch it
it's like yeah they're either gonna
watch it or not yeah i feel like
we're in this time where i'm like can
you watch it can you watch it it's like
soft pitch i've never been like this
person really needs me to watch this
don't watch it yeah okay well you're not
in the microphone so you're not saying
anything
don't launch it
i don't want them to watch it i don't
need the views it's mostly transphobic
this is home i know how to get people to
watch your special it's transphobic it's
it's yeah wall-to-wall an hour-long
transphobic joke i'm thinking about
saying that
and i'm sorry the special's called
career suicide i'm like you guys you
guys should watch my special i really
just talk about how i think like trans
people or just like shouldn't be
in sports don't write elephants
[Laughter]
emily's ulcer is the name of the next
special
[Music]
[Applause]
you